If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you will also appear with him and glory.
Well, good morning church. You all looked refreshed after that. Uh,
extra hour of sleep last night. Uh,
except for you young parents where your kids woke up an hour early this morning.
I know that feeling. We've done that before in our lives. Uh,
if you're new here, we're grateful you would choose to gather with us.
It's an honor that you would,
and we wanna get to know you and meet you if we can.
So please come say hello to us up here at the front after there's a big new here
section out there. We'd love to help you connect to our church.
Hope you feel welcomed and encouraged.
I know it's hard to visit a new church and so we wanna invite you to,
to take a step forward as God would lead you to be comfortable at that time. Uh,
we're gonna get very practical today in our journey through the New Testament
book of Colossians.
And we're gonna talk today about new creation relationships,
how if you have been made a new creation in Christ through the life,
death and resurrection of Christ or faith in him,
then you are new now.
And so you can put on the new self you've been made new so you
can live a new life. But that doesn't just affect our lives generally,
which we can kind of tend to think that way.
It actually even affects the deepest and the closest
relationships we have on this earth.
Marriage, parenting, the workplace dynamic.
It affects even those things.
And so as I say that before any of you check out of this today
because you're not married or because you don't have kids or because you don't
have a job or whatever,
let me encourage you not to check out immediately because there's gonna
be something today for everyone, for kids.
You'll actually be addressed today directly. Students,
you as well parents,
singles who want to be married.
Even those just kind of questioning how authority works in general.
Like this is all going to be comprehensive.
Even if it might not seem like it on the surface,
it's going to actually get to all of us today.
And so take your copy of God's word, turn with me to Colossians chapter three.
Colossians chapter three starting in verse 18 is where we're gonna be today.
And the sections chapter three verse 18 down through chapter four,
verse one. Actually
Colossians three 18 through chapter four, verse one.
Look at it with me.
It'll be on the screen if you don't have one in front of you.
Wives submit to your husbands as is fitting in the Lord.
Husbands love your wives and do not be harsh with them.
Children obey your parents and everything for this pleases the Lord.
Fathers do not provoke your children lest they become discouraged.
Bond servants, obey in everything those who are your earthly masters.
Not by way of I service as people pleasers, but with sincerity of heart,
fearing the Lord. Whatever you do,
work heartily as for the Lord and not for men.
Knowing that from the Lord you'll receive the inheritance as your reward.
You are serving the Lord Christ.
For the wrongdoer will be paid back for the wrong he has done.
And there is no partiality masters.
Treat your bond servants,
justly and fairly knowing that you also have a master
in heaven. Lord, this is your word.
It's not just for them back then. It's not
just merely words on a page, God.
This is your very words to us.
So we need you to work through those words, to empower your people,
to live out your words and not be hearers. Only.
God, make our hearts right now good soil. Remove distractions from our minds.
Things we might be thinking about from yesterday or this morning or tomorrow
just to say, no God, we want you.
We wanna see you today.
So help us Holy Spirit speak in Jesus' name.
Amen.
So I know there's some tricky language in this passage and we'll we'll get to
that in a moment, but,
but what's gonna help us first is to understand the difference that Christ made
back then. So when Colossae, when Christ entered their lives,
what was the difference that he would make then?
Remember it was a majority pagan dark environment.
That's where they lived in Colossae.
And so how were Christians to live in that situation?
Well,
part of the context we need to understand when we read this is that a household,
you might say the quote unquote household back then was more than just a single
family unit like it often is today. There was the,
the so-called head of the house, the man of the house, his wife in,
in a household,
there were even adult children and their families that would live with them,
even extended family would often be there. They had servants,
they had employees, they would even have other people that lived with them.
And this was a household in the context here.
So when you see often in scripture these binary pairs, so husband,
wife, master, slave, father, child, like you see these often. Ephesians five,
one, Peter two and three, Titus two. It happens a lot.
That's what it's talking about is this whole household and how they should
interact. And back then this was the common structure for households even,
even for unbelievers. This was not a Christian thing,
this was just the way it was in society.
And so Paul here,
he's not encouraging some kind of subversion to the culture 'cause he's
gonna say next week we'll see in verse five of chapter four,
we should walk in wisdom toward outsiders.
Meaning we should be careful what they think about us.
So he wasn't saying blow the whole system up. He's saying No,
you can live in this system.
He's not bringing anything new to the table in that sense.
But here's what he was doing. He was bringing something very new.
What was new was the way that those household members were to treat one another.
Now
that it wasn't just the law of nature or the law of the culture anymore.
It was the law of Christ that dictated how things
worked out.
What was different Paul's teaching them here was Christ's
Lordship over the household.
What was different was Christ's lordship over
the household that that this was a way to show transformation
to the culture around them.
They couldn't just apply the old worldly ways of doing things anymore.
They had to listen to how God wanted them to do the house
he's Lord over even the household.
But not only is he Lord over the household directing how it's supposed to be,
he's also head within the household.
He's he, he's making a difference here.
Christ is making the difference through his headship within the
household. He's Lord over it saying Here's how it should be set up.
And his headship within the household changes everything.
I wanna be careful to explain this because there have been some sad and
weird things done in the name of headship,
especially in the context of a marriage.
The idea of being the head of something is used all over scripture in various
ways, but,
but we've already seen it back in chapter one here in Colossians chapter one,
verse 18. It says that Christ is the head of the body,
the church. So he's the head of the body.
Yet also chapter two verse 19.
It says that holding fast to the head from whom the
whole body that would be the church nourished and knit together through its
joints and ligaments, it grows with a growth that is from God.
So headship is more than just commanding and
directing how things should go. There's a nourishing and a knitting together.
That's the context in which Ephesians five,
which Colossians and Ephesians are very parallel and he's probably writing them
at the same time to different people.
If Ephesians 5 23 says the husband is the head of the
wife, even as Christ is the head of the church,
his body and is himself its Savior.
So there's a parallel he makes between the headship of Christ on the church and
the headship of a husband with a wife. Now lemme be clear.
In no way is the husband able to save the wife like Christ saves us.
That doesn't parallel there of course, but this means,
and hear this clearly,
the form of headship that a husband has is
shaped by Christ, right? He puts those together.
And so think about what Christ did for his bride,
for the church.
He loved her by dying for her,
by sacrificing for her, by Colossians two,
nourishing her, protecting her.
Mark 10 45,
Jesus said even the son of man came not to be served but
to serve and to give his life as a ransom for many
so Christ headship within the home,
not just the church within the home here.
It changes the way we exemplify headship in our
relationships. And that was what was totally revolutionary in Colossi
because a husband who back then had every right to demand his wife,
wife to do virtually anything
instead as a new creation he was supposed to keep on loving her.
That's the tense of the verb. To love her in an ongoing way, in a tender way.
He's supposed to care and serve for her like Christ did the church.
That's a complete revolutionary concept back then.
A parent
who back then treated their children very little differently than a hired hand,
as a, a farm laborer.
Instead as a new creation in Christ was to, to not provoke them,
was to lead them in the discipline instruction of the Lord. Ephesians six,
four says, that's a whole different concept.
And so when the husband would do that for his wife,
that that led her to willingly follow his loving leadership.
When a parent did that for a child,
it would lead the child to gladly obey as a way to honor Christ.
That changed the whole thing.
And then you think about this master slave relationship,
a master who back then could treat his bond servants as property with no
rights. Instead he's saying, no,
you to be just and fair with those that
work for you that are in your household, which would lead those servants.
Think about that.
To work hard with sincerity of heart because they know their master cares for
them new creations in Christ.
Again,
the the the structure of the household back then might not have
looked much different than the rest of the world around them.
But what was different was Christ's lordship over the household
and Christ's headship within the household.
And that's what would have caused them to stand out in really radical ways
back then. And hear me,
it's still what will make the Christian household today
stand out as well.
This is not just talking about the way things were back then and how different
it could have been.
It's still what will make the Christian household stand out today.
He made a massive difference in a pagan world back then.
He still makes a difference today.
So we're gonna walk back through this and first we're gonna see the difference
that Christ makes in marriage.
Like this new creation kingdom that we live in now,
the new relationships we have because of that, the new self that we are,
look at the difference it makes in a marriage.
It changes it in so many distinct ways. Look again, verses 18 and 19,
wives submit to your husbands as is fitting in the Lord.
Husbands love your wives and do not be harsh with them.
Now to some verse 18 is pretty patriarchal. See,
this is just Paul trying to keep women down or
that was the way the context was back then. But that doesn't really apply today.
We're in a different stage of history.
Well, remember what I said earlier,
if Paul was just trying to perpetuate the cultural realities
of the time, he absolutely could have done that,
but he didn't.
Even though the structure might look similar, the reality
is that the new creation,
it completely changes the way that husbands and wives interact now
because remember,
God's word never sees women as less than men.
Culture, remember culture at the time did when they were writing this.
But listen, especially to what Paul says,
others say similar things. But this is what Paul says.
Galatians 3 28 and 29 for example, he says,
there is neither talking about the church. Those who have put on Christ.
There's neither Jew nor Greek. There's neither slave nor free.
There is no male and female for you are all one in Christ Jesus.
And if you are Christ,
then you are Abraham's offspring airs according to promise.
Now that phrase, those verses have been really misunderstood.
Don't misunderstand what he's saying.
He's not saying that somehow in Christ you stop being
who God created you to be.
Because remember in that church in Galatia,
some of those people had been born in Jewish families and some had been born
somewhere else. They were Greeks, gentiles,
some were in a slavery situation for whatever reason, while some were free,
some were male and some were female. It,
it's the same thing today, right? I I am still from Fairview,
I'm still a man. I'm 40. So that makes me a man, right? So that's like you,
you see how I didn't change any of that when I became a Christian?
You're still from Idabell or wherever you're from, you're still a woman.
You're right. You see how this works out.
It's just that what he's saying there is that in Christ
that means you are all equally saved.
There's no levels in the kingdom, there's no,
there's no hierarchy in the church in a sense like this, right?
You're saved with everyone else. 'cause remember what happened back then.
Remember what there's, he's referring to here.
The culture at the time devalued people who were not Jewish.
They devalued women. They devalued slaves. And so Paul says, no,
no, actually
you're all equal before the cross.
You're all heirs of God's promise. Not just these few people,
not just this situation or this context.
You're all heirs together of God's promise.
And so when you hear this call for wives to submit to their husbands,
it has nothing to do with value or with worth or
with equality. It has to do with order.
And I don't say that meaning the the husband can order his wife around. No,
it's about this idea of leading almost like a dance together, right? Who's,
who's taking the lead in the dance and and hear this
clearly
a husband's role as the head of his wife
is in the spirit of Ephesians chapter five,
verses 25 through 30 clearly says, husbands,
love your wives ongoing.
Keep loving your wives as Christ loved the church and gave himself up for
her that he might sanctify her,
having cleansed her by the washing of water with the word so that he might
present the church to him himself in splendor without spot or wrinkle
or any such thing that she might be holy and without blemish
In the same way
husbands should love their wives as their own bodies.
He who loves his wife actually loves himself for no one ever hated his own
flesh,
but nourishes and cherishes it just as Christ does the
church because we are members of his body.
Listen, men, that's what headship is.
That is what headship is in a marriage. It's it's serving,
it's giving.
It's dying to self so you can die for her.
And you saw it in Colossians three, there is zero harshness in that
you are not supposed to demand or be this authoritarian figure.
That's not what headship is. Headship is what Christ did for the church.
And wives, listen as you willingly follow his loving leadership,
it's mutually
serving and giving and dying to self so you can die,
die for him.
It works the best whenever both are giving and serving and dying for
each other. That's how marriage is truly healthy.
But I also want you to notice this women,
this submission we're talking about is not to all men
says in Ephesians five, submit to your own husband
and hear that it is fitting in the Lord.
That means it is making sense according to God's design.
That's the way it's designed to be. Which means that it's ultimately here.
This it's not your husband, it's you're submitting to the Lord ultimately,
right? That's the the,
the idea here is that submission does not trump your submission
to follow the Lord. First and foremost,
the command to follow Jesus.
You should never follow your husband into sin.
You follow Christ above all.
That takes precedence every single time. Which also means husband,
you should not ever lead your wife into sin.
You should not tempt her
that she would drift away from Christ in some way. No, your job,
as Ephesians five said, is to lead her towards sanctification,
not towards sin.
Make it easy to follow that loving leadership
because remember husband Christ is your head too
and he will repay. There is no partiality.
So that's marriage. What about in parenting?
Look at the difference that Christ makes today in parenting as well.
Read again verses 20 and 21 again, the pair here that he puts together.
Verse 20, children,
obey your parents and everything for this pleases the Lord.
And fathers do not provoke your children lest they become discouraged.
Pretty straightforward, right? Not a lot of complicated things, children.
This is a call to you from the beginning of creation
all throughout scripture. The command is obey your parents.
It pleases the Lord. Ephesians six, three says,
it will actually lead life to be better for you, right?
There's actually a reward that comes with it because think about this,
a constantly rebellious attitude. It only brings strife.
It only brings hardship. If you're always kicking back on your parents,
that's never going to be good for you or for them or for anyone.
And so as long as they don't ask you to sin
again, you're submitted to Christ above all as well.
But as long as they don't ask you to sin and,
and even though you might not understand why they're asking you to do this or
saying do it this way in the Christian household,
obedience to parents is how it works best.
And it's a way for you as a child to model to the world around you that Christ
has made a difference in you.
Which is why the flip side to parents is just as important here.
That parents under the headship of Christ, we're still under that, right?
That they are not to provoke or discourage their
children. That word provoke is actually what it sounds like. Exactly.
Provoking is inciting them to anger, embitter them towards you,
nagging over and over again on them
sarcastically pushing your kids' buttons.
It's provoking and it can be discouraging.
Listen, if you don't want your kids to rebel against you as a parent,
then stop pushing them away.
Draw them to you, love them towards you.
Win their heart back.
I mean, just think of how different the Christian home would be when
parents and children love and honor one another and
everyone is built up in the Lord in that way. Listen,
the new self that God's given us can do that.
Parents can do that. Children can do that.
Just think of the beautiful picture that gives the world.
And finally the last section is passage deals with the difference Christ makes
today in our work. So marriage,
parenting work.
Now I know Colossians talks about masters and slaves as delicate subject,
but that was the reality in which work often happened back then.
Maybe it was what we call indentured servanthood,
where somebody's paying off a debt that they have towards someone where they're
so abjectly, poverty, uh, poverty stricken, that they just have to do this.
They kinda sell themselves into this reality. But,
but let me be clear about this.
When you read slavery in this context most often,
in fact nearly all of it was not racially motivated.
That's our, like, we kinda look back through the lens of the 18 hundreds, right?
Like that's, that's not what we're talking about here.
This was an economic reality back then.
That's why we can apply it to our work environments today where there are
similar interactions between employers and employees for economic reasons,
right? We kind of take this today in a way that we live it out.
It's not the same because back then a slave couldn't quit their job or do
something else or move positions like they couldn't do that.
So it is not exactly the same.
But notice what it says again about how we are to work.
Verse 22, down through chapter four. Verse one says,
bond servants obey in everything those who are your earthly masters.
Not by way of I service as people pleasers, but with sincerity of heart,
fearing the Lord. Whatever you do,
work heartily as for the Lord and not for men.
Knowing that from the Lord you'll receive the inheritance as your reward.
You're serving the Lord Christ for the wrong door will be paid back for the
wrong He's done. There is no partiality masters.
Treat your bond servant justly and fairly knowing you also have a master in
heaven. And so again,
slaves had very little rights back then. The master could be harsh with them,
harmful to them. But remember, this letter was written to a church
and the fact that Paul addressed masters and slaves in the church illustrates
the idea I talked about before of the household, right?
It's more than just like a nuclear family.
There's a lot of people involved because at the time,
whole households would come to faith at one time in many cases.
In fact, we see it in Acts 16 with the Philippian jailer in his family.
About midnight Paul and Silas were praying and singing hymns to God in prison.
And the prisoners were listening to them and suddenly there's a great
earthquake. So the foundations of the prison were shaken immediately.
All the doors were open, everyone's bonds were unfastened.
And when the jailer awoke and saw the prison doors were open,
he drew his sword was about to kill himself.
Supposing the prisoners had escaped. But Paul cried out with a loud voice,
do not harm yourself. We're all here. And the jailer called for lights,
rushed in trembling with fear. He fell down before Paul and Silas.
He brought them out and said, SIRS, what must I do to be saved?
Like I've heard you praying and singing these things about the gospel.
What do I do to get what you have? And they said,
believe in the Lord Jesus and you'll be saved, you and your whole household.
And they spoke the word of the Lord to him and to all who were in his house.
They got together with all those people and said, here's the gospel.
And he took them the same hour of the night, washed their wounds.
He was baptized at once, he and all his family.
And then he brought them up into his house, set food before them,
rejoiced along with his entire household that he had believed in. God.
Remember that was his children, extended family, servants, employee.
Like all these people.
That means that all of those people, including the servants, including the kids,
would've been a part of the Colossian church, right?
Because as we saw in Colossians three 11 in Christ, they're now all equal.
No more slave and freed Greek and Jews, circumcised, uncircumcised. No,
we're one in Christ.
But remember that didn't necessarily change their roles in life.
Maybe they did free some slave, but, but that's,
that's why Paul talked here the way they should interact in the new creation
kingdom.
Now how do you handle those relationships you have in the household?
And so for us, first for the employee,
that's our modern language we use for that. Of course,
you ought to willingly follow the employer you have.
Doesn't mean you can't change jobs, but, but ultimately,
remember you're not working for that employer anyway.
They're paying you of course, but but what did it say?
You are serving the Lord Christ.
Remember you're working for God,
not just me or the people getting paid by the church. We don't, yeah,
we work for God in a sense, but but you do too.
You are serving the Lord Christ and he's the one who blesses eternally.
Think about how a slave would've heard that,
that God gives the inheritance because a slave had no possibility of
an inheritance. But Paul says, no,
actually you're gonna get rewarded. The inheritance to come is the eternal one.
You're gonna get that. So stay faithful.
But also they should be encouraged because he is the one who justly,
repays those who are doing wrong.
So the slaves getting mistreated or had been or before and he's,
he's saying to them, no, you don't have to try to take vengeance.
It's God's who's going to repay shows. No partiality.
It doesn't matter the order of the way things work out in creation.
God's got it. So if you're working for the Lord first,
if you go to work tomorrow or this afternoon or whenever you go to work,
you go working for the Lord. That's why you should work hard.
That's the word heartily means from the deepest part of who you are,
not just notice we said it, not just when your boss is watching,
Ooh man, that's gonna get us right work hardily,
not as people pleasers a way of I service. He says, no.
Instead you ought to fear the Lord
that when you put eight hours on your time sheet, but you only worked five,
he sees that
when you steal money or swipe a little,
a little bit here and there from the company or or take advantage of some
policies. That's just a little bit of an ethical nuance. No, he sees that
When you take advantage of your salaried position to come in late and leave
early because you've got enough done, he sees that
even students might not have a job, but your employer,
so to speak, would be those that you're working for at school. Teachers,
leaders in that way. Are you giving your best?
Are you working for the Lord first in school,
stay at home parents. Okay, you don't have a,
a job that pays. You think, this doesn't apply to me at all. No, actually,
listen, you have an incredibly hard job as well,
and the work that you put in often is never ever seen by
anybody else. So you are working for the Lord.
So do it. Well work hard.
But you see how different a picture that would have showed the world around them
back then, right?
It can be the same way today that if you are working like this,
you could be the best employee they have
because God's made you a new creation and you've put on the new self.
But you notice this passage speaks to the employer as well, right?
Where back then, instead of using their slaves,
masters were to treat them justly and fairly. They were to bless them,
they were to treat them like brothers and sisters in Christ as they were.
It didn't negate the level of authority the relationship demanded,
but it changed the way it worked out. Same way today,
if you're a supervisor of anyone in any level,
listen,
nothing in your position gives you the right to be unjust,
to be unfair, to be harsh, to be whatever.
I mean,
just think about the atmosphere you would create when your policies are fair,
when you are paying your people well,
when you're treating your employees with kindness, when you're humble,
when you're repentant, when you have that kind of atmosphere, man,
that screams grace all over it, doesn't it? And people want to be there.
They long to work in that way.
'cause notice where Paul based that command in, in chapter four verse one,
he says, do this masters knowing that you also have a master
in heaven. He said, Hey master, don't forget you're a slave to,
you're a slave to Christ as well. And so you have a submission to him.
That goes us right back to the foundational points today.
That if Christ is Lord over the household,
if Christ is head within the household,
that changes everything about the way we interact.
He calls the shots and he gives the example.
The closest relationships in our lives have the opportunity to show
more than any other way the transformation that Christ brings in our lives.
When our marriages and our parenting and our workplaces are different,
it shows that Christ has truly made a difference.
'cause those people know you better than anyone else does.
My wife knows me better than anyone else.
And so I have every responsibility to treat her in a way that if she
still loves,
if she still comes to and cares for and serves and works together with me,
that shows the world
that there's true love and transformed love in that
they can be the best way to show the world,
or they can be the biggest detractor from the glory of
God. As we live out these relationships, no different than the way of the world.
If our marriages look just like the rest of the world,
if our parenting ways look just like the rest of the world,
if our workplaces look just like the world around us, there's no difference.
And it actually pulls down the glory of God.
So hear me, church, we have to be different.
If we claim to be new creations through the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus Christ, that we have placed our faith in him.
That new self we put on, looks like this in our relationships.
Colossians three 17, we ended with this last week. Whatever you do
in word or deeded,
do everything in the name of the Lord Jesus,
giving thanks to God the Father through Him. Everything,
whatever you do. So
be single to the glory of God.
Be married to the glory of God,
parent to the glory of God. Work to the glory of God,
all because you have a new name that's over you.
It's the name of Christ.
You're doing it in His name and for His name.
Whatever you do in everything in everything,
do it in the name of the Lord Jesus.